this is what remains of Fort Myers Beach
it's the warm Waters of the Gulf of
Mexico which bring people here
but yesterday They Carried the full Fury
of hurricane Ian
a wall of water 10 feet high washing
Away Homes and businesses
in the exact spot where that video was
filmed these stairs are all that's left
of the orange house on the beachfront
the story of its occupants told by a
neighbor it was floating right it was
floating and then they got swept away
and one guy ended up in a palm tree
right across the street over there at
that house
he was there for about a minute and then
he was gone
lost Away by the fourth
do you know what happened to them
they're dead I mean there's no the storm
continued for at least another six hours
there's no way they could have survived
and there was nothing we could do I mean
for us that's for me that's going to be
the hardest thing to live with you know
I'm alive and I'm thankful for that but
there are a lot of people who aren't
as Dawn broke search and rescue efforts
began
those who survived leaving a place that
looks little like they remember
lives packed into a suitcase have you
ever seen a storm like this never I
lived in Florida my whole life but never
seen nothing like this do you think
people were caught by surprise at how
strong it was
they kept saying it was going to hit
Tampa and the next day you would wake up
in the morning and said nurse
you can only imagine what it must have
been like to have been here yesterday
afternoon as the water began to rise
washing away the Fort Myers pier and
moving its way onto the main Beach area
storm surge up to 12 feet high in places
here quite literally washing away this
part of Fort Myers Beach a strip that
would usually be full of restaurants and
bars quite literally flattened
the area of impact is unprecedented here
boats dragged from their Moorings and
dumped more than a mile away
in Island Park residents say Walter Rose
from ankle to chest level in 10 minutes
Cindy is trying to reach her family
including two-year-old granddaughter
Chloe
she's being driven by Rich a fishing
guide who worked through the night
rescuing people first in a boat now in a
pickup truck
we're getting close I told you they are
so far now the other way would have been
a little closer but they would the trees
that's their building straight in front
of us
it is eventually a happy reunion after
an anxious way not everyone in this part
of Florida will be so fortunate Martha
Kellner Sky News Fort Myers Beach